I think we can all agree that robots are
pretty cool we can probably also agree
that they can't be completely trusted
here's everything you need to know about
atomic heart
[Music]
atomic heart takes place during a
fictional alternative reality version of
the 1955 USSR following the invention of
a special substance called polymer in
1936 scientist Dimitri sectionov
launched a massive network of artificial
intelligence called Collective the goal
was to create AI assistance that could
make the lives of humans Easier by
freeing them of manual labor the good
news is that it worked for nearly two
decades before things took a turn for
the worst the game picks up during the
launch of collective 2.0 and a new
device called thought that would allow
humans to control the network using just
their minds unfortunately the launch was
sabotaged and as a result robots began
to attack humans leading to hundreds of
deaths put pressure on this movement
they try to save you play as sectionov's
best agent major nichayev AKA P3 ichayev
was named after the third of the
discovered radioactive elements
plutonium an element that nearly took
his life following a laboratory exposure
the whole ordeal has left P3 with a
fragmented memory PTSD and metal
Prosthetics but he still knows how to
get the job done by any means necessary
as P3 you are sent to the top secret
military base facility 3826 in order to
investigate the incident and restore the
neural network
[Music]
atomic heart is a first person shooter
style action role-playing game so you
can expect to fire lots of weapons
throughout your play time of roughly 25
hours Inside Your Arsenal are a mix of
the latest developments in melee and
ranged Weaponry from section off and
facility 3826 this list includes tools
like a sharp ax a modified electric
rifle and most importantly the polymer
glove if you're familiar with games like
Bioshock then this glove's power might
sound familiar to the left-hand
abilities of that game as you'll be able
to shoot electricity ice and Trigger
telekinesis right from p3's fingertips
inside the glove lives Charles an AI
sidekick that will provide story
objectives and secrets as well as scan
the area and hack other robots the
game's robots are all interconnected and
controlled by the AI of the collective
this can make these robots a challenge
to deal with as they can communicate and
even repair each other the good part
about this system is that if you hack
into the collective's network of control
terminals you'll gain an advantage over
your foes however you shouldn't expect
all of your enemies to be AI controlled
hunks of metal some of what you'll be
fighting are scientific plants that have
the ability to mutate human bodies and
deal incredible amounts of damage the
game's combat isn't quite like your
typical Shooters and according to early
previews atomic heart borrows from the
souls-like genre what I mean by this is
that running and gunning won't get you
very far and your enemies will require a
bit of patience as you wait for the
right moment to strike fortunately the
developers revealed that there will be
three difficulty settings in atomic
heart story medium and hard regardless
of which one you choose you're going to
want some strong weapons by your side
every step of the way and atomic heart's
crafting system allows for you to create
an enhanced Arsenal for your specific
playstyle upgrade weapons with different
Scopes magazines barrels grips and
Elemental ammo all of which can be
crafted using materials that you
scavenge from around the environment and
even though crafting ammo sounds very
handy you'll also have the option of
looting ammo or accumulating energy
through melee combat that can be used as
a munition for special energy weapons
the open world of atomic heart is
divided into five sections that can be
explored Faster by car and even faster
by aerotrain each section is a large
scientific complex filled with enemies
to take down and puzzles to complete the
puzzles seem to play an important role
in the game and based on early previews
can take anywhere from 15 minutes to an
hour to complete these locations include
Pavlov complex a once Military Hospital
that is now being used for organic and
biomolecular chemistry the other four
locations are vavilov vdnh cyclin and
Neptune but none of them have
descriptions on the developer's website
at the time of this video's recording
the car is the debuted game from
developer mudfish and it's being
published by Focus entertainment the
game's music was provided by Doom 2016's
MC Gordon and in an interview with IGN
Atomic Hearts director Robert bagratuni
described the soundtrack as quote Soviet
style Pop Meets juicy Doom style remixes
in a separate interview with Digital
Trends Robert spoke a little about
comparisons to other games like Bioshock
and explained that he sees little value
in making clones instead of trying to
just make another Bioshock he wanted to
make a game that is constantly adding
layers of action that genuinely
surprised the player those added layers
are most likely what increased the scale
of the game which led to the studio
dropping their plans for a co-op mode
foreign
atomic heart will be available on
February 21st for PlayStation 4
PlayStation 5 Xbox One series X and S
and PC via Steam and the Microsoft store
prices for the game will vary depending
on the platform you plan to play on As
the console versions will run you 10 USD
more than the PC versions the good news
is that game pass subscribers won't have
to pay any extra to enjoy atomic heart
because it will be available on the
service upon release however if you
don't have Game Pass there are three
versions of the game for you to choose
from standard gold and premium the
standard edition of the game comes with
a digital copy and that's all the Gold
Edition will come with the game an
exclusive polymer glove skin and the
atomic pass your gateway to all four of
atomic Hearts planned waves of DLC the
Premium Edition will come with
everything I listed for the Gold Edition
as well as two other exclusive weapon
skins and a digital art book with
additional information about the game
ear players who pre-order the game will
have ax access to two other exclusive
weapon skins one for the Swede ax and
the other for the electro atomic heart
has robots guns and Elemental smart
glove challenging combat and puzzles
plus a story packed with surprises and
that's all you need to know about the
game for more on atomic heart including
our review and guides make sure to
subscribe and keep an eye on
gamespot.com
thank you
foreign